hello and welcome to machine learning
for biomedical data an introductory
course to applied high-throughput data
analysis this course is brought to you
by the Georgetown Medical Center in
collaboration with Pine biotech a
company specializing in big biomedical
data analysis in this lecture we will be
learning about high-throughput
biomedical data what it is where it came
from and where we can find it to analyze
and prepare for machine learning medical
data or simply clinical data is the type
of information that we have been using
in clinical use for centuries
temperature heart rate and other data
that is on the surface but with the
advent of cellular and molecular biology
we've learned how health and disease are
driven by what's happening deeper at the
cellular level biomedical data refers to
the combination of clinical and omics
data or the information about the
underlying biology which has several
layers of omics these include genomics
proteomics and even the microbiome these
onyx datatypes are high throughput this
means that they produce a large quantity
of observations for each sample
phenomics refers to phenotype how cells
look their shape and types genomics
refers to the DNA sequence that contains
single nucleotide polymorphisms and
other variation at the DNA level
epigenomics refers to epigenetic
variation like histone modification and
methylation transcriptomics can data
contains information on gene expression
and its variation like alternative
splicing there are other our mix as well
that represent different levels of data
that all contribute to a single puzzle
but how did this data become so widely
accessible after all it's very expensive
to produce and on trivial to use let's
see the amazing speed at which one of
these data types
genomics became widely accessible and
commonly used in biomedical research and
even clinical practice throughout the
world in the 1950s
in 60s the structure and function of DNA
was discovered it took almost 50 years
for that knowledge to be used to
sequence the human genome that was
completed in 2003 today Francis Collins
who led the human genome project is the
director of National Institutes of
Health
and his main competitor at that time
craig Venter recently co-founded one of
his many startups human longevity this
company seeks to extend human life using
Clues found in multi-omics data in 2006
Illumina was launched bringing shotgun
sequencing to the masses in 2015 the
1000 genome project brought a
significant number of whole genome
sequences to the research community and
today in 2018 over 100,000 whole genomes
were sequenced at the Broad Institute
and over 50 thousand genomes at genomics
England the growth in high-throughput
data is largely driven by cheaper faster
and more efficient sequencing called
next-generation sequencing or simply NGS
from 100 million in 2001 to
approximately 3 million in 2008 and
today the cost of a sequenced genome is
about $1,000 why is the price that
you're good parameter to assess the
availability of genomic data it is
because other standard medical tests on
average cost between 250 and 800 dollars
the widespread use of these technologies
gives us a benchmark to assess the
prevalence and accessibility of genomic
data for clinical and biomedical
research uses so we addressed the
question of cost that was primarily
driven by research advances and a
gradual transition to effective
technologies that was quickly scaled up
the second issue is the use of this data
how do you analyze that rich data set
many
measurements healed single numbers of
each observation for example height in
inches or centimeters weight in pounds
or kilograms and age and years using
such numbers you can learn something but
the detail and depth of that information
is limited it is also intuitive the here
on the chart we can see a clear
separation in two dimensions weight
projection projected on the y axis and
height on the x axis a straight line
separates between male and female
patients omics on the other hand yields
tens of thousands of data points for
each sample each element let's say a
gene will have a number associated with
its expression
there are approximately 20,000 protein
coding genes in the human genome so to
work with such high-throughput date one
must rely on methods that can handle
this kind of complexity so it's not
surprising that at the same time that
the human genome was sequenced we can
see a dramatic increase in machine
learning publications and patents
machine learning methods are used to
process analyze visualize and integrate
these high-throughput data sets
availability of data development of new
tools and computing power making make it
essential for us to understand current
state-of-the-art in biomedical data
analysis so let's begin by identifying
tools and datasets that we will use in
our course inner course will be relying
on the T bio info multi-omics analysis
platform that provides a user-friendly
interface for analysis visualization and
integration of omics data the platform
is designed for both newbies and experts
providing advanced high performance
computing capabilities and a combination
of proprietary and open source tools for
analysis we will use public domain data
sets from NCBI the National Center for
Biotechnology information our
I told you that we will be learning by
working through projects so let's get
started the first data set will focused
on cancer to give you a statistic 1.6
million people die from cancer every
year in the US alone 10 to 20 percent of
these deaths are estimated to be from
misdiagnosis or delayed diagnosis so the
first data set that we will use actually
showcases how machine learning can be
applied to multi AMEX oncology data the
publication is interesting because the
authors assembled the data set of about
50 different breast cancer cell lines
that represent the whole spectrum of
breast cancer variations the cell lines
have genomic transcriptomics and
proteomics data as well as an efficacy
measurement of commonly used in
experimental cancer drugs for our next
lecture please spend some time reading
through the publication you can find it
on this link I hope to see you in our
next lecture where we will discuss the
processing of high-throughput data we
will also review the data we have so
make sure you are familiar with the
publication so you can follow along